joining me now is Sabrina Sofer a Jewish
student at GW University and a witness
to last night's anti-semitic incident on
campus Sabrina what were your first
thoughts when you saw those messages
about the murty of Hamas projected onto
that Library wall at
gwu hi yes so I'm here actually standing
in front of the Gman Library uh at the
George Washington University in the main
Square uh kogan Plaza and I was notified
of these um these slogans while I was
coming back from an event and I was you
know I was very shocked but I was not
surprised and I'll tell you why I think
that Jewish students have been warning
of this kind of radical ideology by
anti-israel groups on campus and this is
just one extreme manifestation that
they're really showing their true colors
here and this is absolute anti-Semitism
and what is happening is that there's a
lot of radical ideology that's going on
in the classroom where terrorism is
being justified and very Insidious ways
and it's very concerning so when I say
that I'm not surpr I'm shocked but I'm
not
surprised this ideology is coming out
and it's coming out in public now so my
my first reaction was yes of course I'm
I'm fearful Jewish students are fearful
but again we shouldn't be uh surprised
now listen to what one protester Sabrina
said to the police when this vigil that
they called it was shut
down can't shut it down because other
people
are
people people
areat should be to protect us from those
threat you're so so kind for letting us
have a vigil for our martyr that's not
what I'm
saying Sabrina were other students who
are concerned were they being violent
no student who came last night was being
violent Jewish students saw this
projected on their Library while they
were literally trying to go walk and and
study but this was projected so how can
you not stop and see what's happening so
there's no way that us Gathering there
was any sort of an incitement nor did we
even engage with them we didn't talk to
them we just wanted to see what was
going on and it really wasn't until it
was clear made clear by the school that
this is against campus policy that um
there was actually an intervention by
the police of course very respectful
saying that look this is not allowed um
just pack up and go we can do this very
peacefully but unfortunately the
students did not want to move or get out
of the way uh pack they didn't want to
pack up their stuff and go and
ultimately what happened is one of the
students uh got up after a five minute
debate or so the one that was just
depicted on the screen and started
shouting free free Palestine um and the
whole other the the Plaza split into two
there was one side of people screaming
anti-israel anti-semitic slogans at the
top of their lungs and the Jewish
students decided to congregate on the
other side of the plaza and sing a song
called Do shalom it's a song for peace
so that's really the difference you see
here there's one side that's inciting
violence through their hateful speech
and there's another side that's
constantly trying to bring peace and um
really just praying for a better
tomorrow that all this hatred stops so
no we are not in inciting violence the
Jewish students on this campus speaking
for myself of course we are in no way
inciting anything all we want is peace
on our campus and no escalation of
anything further well Sabrina we're
watching this very closely we appreciate
it thank you so much